阿蘇兄ちゃん肇社長でスカートショップによく行くんですけどそのカードショップに何
かガチャガチャもたくさんあるんですよ非常に合体形で凄い面白そうなよ
間違ってたらちょっと買ってみました
ヴォノロン
きたこちらアジカルマジックネーミングセンスを疑う何やら水の中にいる時だけ固まっ
てそうじゃない時はただのすばらしいです ic と思った時に合わせてみ時遅かった
気づいたら週回まわしてみました前世欲しかったから仕方ないこればかりはこういうの
はなんとなく全種類
で集めたくなるタイプの人間なのだ記者におしゃれ応用利き方も出ているんだ
持ってい
[音楽]
th
や媒体でこちらの6色になりますん
下まで水を持っていきましょうお金がちょっと思う存分遊ぶために最高のフィールド
準備したからな
これだけでかかったら遊び放題者を入れますねこれで固まるんでしょだって
ブーブーウッドポッっ
[音楽]
もうすごいすごい
木森うすぐ済むと蛇みたいになっちゃったこれすごいそれで全職だしてみましょう
おおぉ凄いねこれすごいなぁなってつい楽しいんだけど
多いなぁうわぁ凄い滑るするよああいう役もいいよああっもうちょい多くのちょっと区
梅田ちょっちょっとちょいでこんな感じでございまー著
しょっちゅうドゥカティのかあもうこんな感じでねちょっとは本当にロス変わると思い
ますこんな感じですこれ混ぜたらカラフルなちょっと混ぜてみよう
失礼しまーすちょっちょっ全部固まっ中根のみたいになりますねこれを地上に立った
そのよそうなんだけど
きっ
砂にがちょっともう本当にすらぞ
ちょっと待って終わり落ちねーのか本当でもすぐになるからすごいですよ
[音楽]
はぁ私は思ってしまった
このすなぁ
動画的に応用力がないすごく楽しいなこれはもうワクワクバックわけだよ
あっはぁや店やこれどうすんだよ
水の中だと面倒になり常に出せばすぐになる
それだけじゃないか
[音楽]
ブーブーって
フェチ米失明するところでしょ自ら花と砂になるということはいますなになってますよ
ね溝乗せてもう
弾くんすよ水をもしこの水をはじくもしこの水にへ
もうかんだから筆あなたは誰水を弾くということは弾かない水だったらひょっとしたら
この子たちは地上でもひょっとしてこいつはちゃん年度として使えるかもしれない
どうしても地上絵になる瞬間すライン夏はかわいそうなことじゃ何とかして年度にする
ために地上に出たこの1000冊にローザ御縁かけて市場
なんなんとか両生類にしてあげたいんですよ僕は霊生霊にしてあげた一の国と水の国
両方の国でちゃんと活躍できるようにちょっと僕から選んでこの子達を地上でも年度に
できるにしてみたいと思います人は全姉砂の姿でなるべく口移してあげよ
結構言ったでしょもう水を外れてるわけですこういうふうにたよ車前たそれが作ってる
からな
うーんまぁこんなだったこの形はちゃんと
ビッグでも賛同して年度になれるのでしょうかちょっぺペローションをかけてみ
ましょう
これで戻ったらん
いいんじゃないでもパート混濁バンクないよなんか何か良い感じで今のところは
ちょっと触ってみますよ
う
ん
ななぜこれなにこれ待って
ああああああ
スライヴになっちゃった凄い是永ローションがスライムになる
ローションだってこんなにてにもてナイススライムですね結構これ大発見ですよ
ローション+魔法主なんでスライムができることが今回分かりました
すごいこれはでもマジでから繰り出すねっというかみなさんもし魔法の砂持っていたが
ローションと混ぜてスライム作ってみてはいかがでしょうか
じゃあ
これは何に使うんだろう
me
ああああああ
バッハ